est ce que nous méritons notre succès ou
bien celui ci n'est t-il due qu'au
hasard
c'est la question à laquelle on répond
aujourd'hui génériques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques mois le vidéaste montée
de la chaîne linguistic ae a publié une
vidéo intitulée je ne mérite pas mon
succès montée est un youtube heures qui
fait des vidéos de vulgarisation dans le
domaine de la linguistique mais la vidéo
à laquelle je vais réagir aujourd'hui
porte sur une question philosophique une
question qu'on pourrait résumer de la
manière suivante
sommes nous responsables de notre succès
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai eu envie de
réagir à cette vidéo est bien d'abord
parce qu'elle touche un sujet qui
m'intéresse particulièrement à savoir la
question de la liberté et du
déterminisme mais aussi parce que le
propos défendu par monter dans sa vidéo
me semble au minimum très contestable et
comme ça fait plusieurs fois que
j'entendais vidéaste tenir ce discours
sur la question de la liberté
j'ai eu envie de mettre les pieds dans
le plat et expliquer pourquoi
l'argumentation défendu par monter me
semble en grande partie incorrect alors
qu'on soit bien d'accord il ne s'agit
pas d'un clash mais d'une confrontation
d'idées et d'ailleurs je n'hésiterai pas
à dire quand je serais d'accord avec les
arguments avancés par monter dans sa
vidéo pour reprendre les choses à la
base
quelle est la thèse défendue par monter
c'est de dire que les personnes qui
réussissent ne peuvent pas s'attribuer
le mérite de leur succès
car la réussite d'abord une affaire de
chance
je ne mets pas mon succès aussi mince ou
relativise abl soit il c'est peut-être
tout simplement parce que le mérite
n'existe pas comme et quand tu peux dire
un truc pareil bien sûr que le mail ça
existe regard d'un tel il a galéré toute
sa vie et ça finit par payer
il ya certainement eu de la chance
[ __ ] mais comment tu peux ni de ses
qualités
et moi j'ai bossé dur pour arriver où
j'en suis tu penses que je suis une
merde qui mérite pas sa place c'est ça
non mais tu as certainement eu de la
chance
ma frangine c'est une super super
intelligente vraiment tu crois qu'ils
auraient pu bosser dans cette superbe
wattao monter sa start-up
révolutionnaire sans toutes ces matières
glisse exceptionnelle parce que l'on
peut-être que non mais toujours est-il
qu'elle a eu de la chance
pour être tout à fait honnête avec toi
monter lorsque j'ai visionné ce passage
pour la première fois j'ai cru qu'il
s'agissait d'une parodie pourquoi ce que
j'ai cru ça parce que l'argument de la
chance comme cause unique de la réussite
sur lequel on va revenir dans la suite
de cette vidéo cet argument repose sur
une confusion entre deux choses très
différentes à savoir la chance et la
faveur la chance c'est un phénomène
purement aléatoire c'est quelque chose
qui ne dépend pas de notre volonté ni de
nos efforts par chance c'est quand un
événement heureux ce produit sans qu'il
y ait de lien de causalité avec les
actions de celui qui en bénéficie par
exemple si vous vous baladez dans un
parc et que vous tombez sur une valise
remplie de billets sur laquelle il est
écrit
tenez c'est cadeau signé bill gates là
on peut parler de chance parce que vous
n'aviez rien entrepris pour arriver à un
tel résultat
vous ne pouviez pas vous doutez en
allant vous balader dans ce parc que
vous alliez tombé sur une valise pleine
de billets donc là oui on peut parler de
chance maintenant si vous apprenez qu'il
y a un trésor qui se cache quelque part
et que vous entreprenez des recherches
pendant des mois pour le trouver
si vous y arrivez vous aurez peut-être
bénéficié de la faveur des événements
mais vous ne devrez pas entièrement
votre découverte à la chance si vous
préférez la chance n'aura joué qu'un
rôle auxiliaires dans la découverte de
votre trésor ce qui aura réellement
rendu possible votre découverte se sont
d'abord vos efforts
en clair la chance c'est quand la part
qui revient à notre action est
inexistante dans l'obtention d'un
résultat alors que la faveur c'est quand
notre action a joué un rôle dans
l'obtention du résultat c'est quand le
résultat est conditionné par des
paramètres sur lesquels nous avons un
pouvoir de m
si vous cherchez un emploi vous n'allez
pas envoyer votre cv dans une seule
entreprise en vous disant j'en vois un
cv et je l'espère la chance vous allez
encore moins rester chez vous à attendre
qu'un patron de boîte vous appelle pour
vous proposer un emploi parce que ça
vous savez que ça n'arrivera pas ce que
vous allez faire et qu'on a tous fait
quand on chercher du boulot
si vous allez envoyer votre cv dans
plusieurs entreprises pour augmenter vos
chances d'être pris et cd vous allez
envoyer vous allez le travail et vous
allez le peaufiner vous allez faire en
sorte que ce soit ce cv qui soit retenue
donc vous allez chercher des modèles sur
internet vous allez peut-être utilisé un
logiciel graphique vous allez faire
attention à l'orthographe
bref vous allez agir sur un maximum de
paramètres maîtrisable pour influencer
le résultat en votre faveur
c'est une simple question de probabilité
plus on optimise chacune des variables
sur lesquels on a une influence et plus
on augmente mécaniquement la probabilité
que l'événement se produise j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'énoncer des
évidences mais apparemment non parce que
à aucun moment une évoque dans ta vidéo
cette différence pourtant fondamentale
entre la chance et la faveur tu parles
de choses comme s'il n'y avait aucune
différence entre le fait d'obtenir un
résultat sans avoir rien fait pour le
provoquer et le fait d'obtenir un
résultat en ayant mis en oeuvre des
efforts pour y parvenir
parce que si tu ne tiens pas compte de
la notion d'effort dont on équation à ce
moment là la question n'a plus de sens
quand on traverse la rue on est bien
d'accord qu'on minimise nos chances de
nous faire écraser en regardant si une
voiture arrive et on trouvera est
absurde de parler de chance parce que
quelqu'un aurait réussi à traverser sans
se faire écraser tout simplement parce
qu'ils avaient le pouvoir d'influencer
le résultat par son comportement
donc on ne peut pas ignorer la
différence entre un événement dont les
paramètres sont en partie maîtrisable un
événement sur lequel notre comportement
aura une incidence est un événement dont
les paramètres échappe totalement à
notre volonté et je m'étonne que tu ne
fasses pas cette distinction pourtant
basique entre un phénomène purement
aléatoire est un phénomène influençable
pour revenir à l'exemple du cv bien sûr
que la chance va jouer un rôle dans le
fait que ce soit ton cv qu'ils soient
retenus par exemple si le patron d'une
entreprise retient la candidature parce
qu'il a vu sur ton cv que vous aviez
fait vos études dans la même fac
là tu pourras parler de chance parce que
c'est quelque chose que tu n'avais aucun
moyen de savoir à l'avancé
ça fait partie des paramètres non
maîtrisables mais n'empêche que si tu
n'avais pas travaillé pour acquérir les
compétences qui sont sur concédé
à ce moment là la chance n'aurait servi
à rien en clair la chance ne peut
intervenir qu'à partir du moment où on a
enclenché une action sans laquelle cette
chance ne se serait jamais manifesté tu
connais peut-être la phrase de thomas
diemer seul qui dit je crois beaucoup à
la chance et je constate que plus je
travaille plus la chance me sourit
ça résume parfaitement les choses la
chance c'est le petit coup de pouce du
hasard qui intervient à partir du moment
où on a déjà entrepris un effort pour
parvenir à un résultat
la chance ne sourit pas aux inactifs
donc quand tu dis montait que tu ne
mérites pas ton succès c'est une belle
preuve d'humilité et c'est tout à ton
honneur mais c'est faux dans la mesure
où tu n'aurait tout simplement jamais
rencontré le succès si tu n'avais pas
entrepris tous les efforts que tu a
entrepris
admettons que chacun ayant réussi mérite
sa place dans la société parce qu'il est
intelligent parce que c'est un génie
parce qu'il a des idées de ouf et que
vous vous considérez vous même comme
intelligent comme un génie comme
quelqu'un ayant des idées de ouf
là pourquoi n'êtes vous pas célèbre
riche quoi ne voit-on pas vos boules sur
bfm business dans le figaro sur un
billboard du métro alors peut-être que
vous n'êtes pas tomber sur le bon prof
en prépa que vous avez dû rage quit ou
alors sur le bon éditeur quand vous avez
ramené ce manuscrit qui devait pourtant
être le prochain best-seller 1
peut-être que vous avez eu un accident
de bagnols aussi le jour de cet
entretien d embauche qui aurait dû
changer votre vie finalement peut-être
vous at il manqué le facteur le plus
déterminant
la chance à ce stade de ta vidéo tu
poses une question qui est si les
personnes qui réussissent réussissent
grâce à leur talent comment se fait-il
que d'autres personnes ayant aussi du
talent ne réussissent pas et la
conclusion ton raisonnement c'est de
dire que ceux qui ont réussi ont surtout
bénéficié du facteur chance ton argument
est très claire sauf que tu commets une
erreur de raisonnement
l'erreur que tu commets sais que tu
réduis le mérite au seul talent sans
tenir compte des autres facteurs du
succès qui ne relève ni du talent ni du
hasard la manière dont tu fermes ta
question est déjà problématique tu dis
si les personnes qui réussissent
réussissent grâce à leur talent mais ça
c'est déjà un raccourci c'est un
raccourci parce que tu présuppose qu'il
ne pourrait pas y avoir de mérite
en dehors du talent or le talent n'est
qu'un élément parmi beaucoup d'autres du
mérite par exemple dans quelle catégorie
ranst eu la persévérance ou range tu la
capacité à créer un réseau de la
capacité à s'exprimer en public
la capacité à récolter des fonds pour
financer un projet toutes ces
compétences ne relève pas directement du
talon et pourtant elle ne relève pas non
plus de la chance en bref pourquoi ton
raisonnement est il un correct parce que
là encore tu confonds deux choses à
savoir le talent et la reconnaissance du
talent le talent rend possible succès
mais la reconnaissance du talent
implique de nombreuses compétences
secondaire qu'ils sont liés ni au hasard
n'y a ce talent lui-même on peut avoir
du talent mais échoué à le faire savoir
on peut avoir du talent et être très
mauvais quand il s'agit de promouvoir ce
talent et ça c'est une erreur qui rend
ton raisonnement caduque
prenons un exemple imaginons un peintre
qui réalisera des toiles absolument
sublime l'étoile qui mériterait d'être
exposé dans les plus grands musées entre
léonard de vinci et eugène delacroix
maintenant imaginons que ce peintre
souffre d'une timidité maladive une
timidité qui l'empêcherait par exemple
de prendre contact avec des gérants
d'établissements pour leur proposer de
faire une exposition
si ce peintre n'est pas en mesure
d'organiser une exposition il ne pourra
pas faire connaître ses oeuvres au
public
et s'il ne fait pas connaître ses
oeuvres au public il lui sera tout
simplement impossible de rencontrer le
succès alors vous allez me dire ok mais
aujourd'hui on a internet pour se faire
connaître aux qu'elle soit mais qui a le
plus de chances de percer sur internet
celui qui n'a jamais été formé et qui
crée un petit site amateur sur wordpress
ou celui qui a des compétences en
infographie en référencement et en
marketing digital
ses compétences on est bien d'accord
qu'elles sont totalement indépendantes
du talent artistique en lui même et
pourtant elles sont déterminantes dans
l'axé à la visibilité donc dans l'axé au
succès de notre artiste
pourquoi est ce que toutes les grandes
entreprises commerciales ou un service
marketing
pourquoi ont-elles un service
communication pourquoi est-ce qu'elles
ont des contrôleurs de gestion des
bureaux d'études des directeurs
commerciaux parce qu'elles savent que
même si le produit qu'elle met sur le
marché est un super produit il a
infiniment plus de chances de se vendre
si on le met en avant que si on se
contente juste de le fabriquer et
d'attendre que les clients tombe dessus
par hasard
donc le succès ce n'est pas seulement du
talent en plus de la chance c'est du
talent et faire savoir qu'on a du talent
c'est la formule gagnante savoir faire
et faire savoir et faire savoir qu'on a
du talent c'est une composante du succès
au moins aussi importante que le talent
en lui-même
sans parler du fait qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont du talent et qui n'est
pas après le succès pour avoir du succès
encore faut-il le vouloir c'est pas
quelque chose d'automatique ça suppose
un minimum de volonté et d'initiatives
pour l'obtenir
et cette initiative cette volonté de
réussir elle est totalement indépendante
du talent en lui même il faut bien que
vous prenez conscience d'une chose c'est
que tous ceux qui ont du succès ont
voulu avoir du succès mais
entendons-nous bien vouloir le succès ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on veut devenir une
superstar mondiale etc la foule nous
acclame ça peut juste vouloir dire qu'on
souhaite que notre travail soit apprécié
et reconnu par le public auquel on
s'adresse
c'est ce que je fais sur ma chaîne c'est
ce que tu fais sur la tienne on fait des
vidéos en espérant qu'elles seront vu
qu'elles seront appréciées et il n'y a
aucun problème avec ça donc si le succès
n'est pas corrélé au talent c'est parce
qu'entre le talent et la reconnaissance
du talent il y à toute la série des
actions intermédiaires qui permettent de
transformer le talent en succès et
déploré le fait que quelqu'un qui a du
talent n'accepte pas la célébrité c'est
faire preuve d'une très grande naïveté
sur la mécanique du succès c'est oublier
la logique du carnet d adresses c'est
oublier la logique du partenariat c'est
oublier la logique de la communication
c'est oublier le talent oratoire le
charisme l'assurance qu'on dégage tous
ces paramètres qui vont intervenir dans
la décision par exemple d'un producteur
d'investir en vous mêmes si ça fait mal
à entendre c'est en grande partie sur
tous ces petits paramètres indépendant
du talent que se construit la mécanique
succès on a tendance à croire que les
grands artistes du passé ont rencontré
le succès sans avoir rien fait pour
l'obtenir mais c'est totalement faux ils
étaient tous obsédés par le succès
vraiment obsédé il faut que cette
histoire pour se rendre compte qu'on a
une vision totalement fantasmée et
idéalisée de l'artiste comme une sorte
d'être pure qui méprisait la réussite
matérielle on en parle de victor hugo
qui disait je veux être chateaubriand ou
rien on en parle de zola qui piquait les
contacts de la maison d'édition où il
travaillait et qui écrivaient des faux
courriers de lectrices pour faire
l'éloge de ses propres livres combien de
biographies de célébrités ont été
écrites pour raconter comment tel acteur
a tout fait pour se retrouver au même
endroit que tel réalisateur
comment tel chanteur a fait le forcing
pour faire éditer son album et même si
on parle des artistes qui ont été
repérés comme on dit ils n'ont pu être
repérée qu'en faisant savoir d'une
manière ou d'une autre qu'il existait le
succès ce n'est pas petit a du talent et
petit b de la chance le succès c'est une
longue série d'actions intermédiaires
qui certes aurait pu ne jamais aboutir
au succès mais sans lesquels ce succès
n'aurait tout simplement jamais été
possible
et comme je sais qu'on va me renvoyé
l'argument du bief du survivant à savoir
que ceux qui réussissent sont une
minorité par rapport à ceux qui échouent
attention je ne dis pas qu'il suffit de
vouloir le succès pour le rencontrer
jeudi qu'il est nécessaire de le vouloir
comme il est nécessaire de postuler dans
une entreprise pour avoir une chance
d'être embauché
la mécanique du succès fonctionne sur le
principe de la sélection concurrentiel
si vous passez un concours la
probabilité que vous et shui et est
généralement plus élevée que la
probabilité que vous soyez admis est ce
que ça signifie pour autant que vous ne
devez pas travailler pour augmenter vos
chances
tous ceux qui ont passé un concours une
fois dans leur vie connaissent la
réponse
comme le note cet article m'ayant donné
envie d'écrire cette vidéo si le mérite
existait si l'on vivait en démocratie on
aurait une redistribution de la richesse
typiquement similaires à celles que l'on
peut trouver sur la redistribution des
résultats de tests de qi ou encore des
heures passées au boulot en courbe de
gauss donc hors la répartition de la
richesse dans un pays ne répond pas à
cette cour et il se trouve qu'on n'a pas
non plus de corrélation entre le fait
d'être dans les plus riches et les plus
talentueux des l'un impliquant à l'autre
le principe de pareto nous montre que
80% de la population se partage 20 % de
la richesse alors que les 20% restants
se partagent 80% de la richesse
les 20 % les mieux lotis ne sont pas les
20% les plus talentueux ou les plus
intelligents et 20% du principe de
pareto ne sont pas les 20% de la fin de
la courbe de gauss la conclusion et je
pense que vous la connaissez déjà pour
devenir riche ou connu un beau célèbre
pour avoir du succès en somme ce n'est
pas tant le talent qui importe dans
cette partie de la vidéo tu t'appuies
sur des données scientifiques pour
démontrer que le succès n'est pas
conditionnée par le mérite et c'est un
argument que j'aurais été tout à fait
prêts à partager
si tu n'avais pas toi-même démolie dans
les secondes qui suivent
car je ne sais pas si tu t'en es rendu
compte mais en concluant que le mérite
n'existe pas tu as khalid en une seule
phrase toute la démonstration qui
précède je vais revenir sur ton
argumentation parce que c'est très
important tout le monde comprenne tu
montre chiffres à l'appui que la courbe
du mérite et la courbe du succès ne sont
pas corrélées autrement dit tu relève à
juste titre que le talent et le travail
ne sont pas les seuls facteurs de la
réussite ce qui rejoint au passage mon
développement précédent sur la mécanique
du succès mais au lieu d'y voir une
anomalie une injustice ou tout bonnement
quelque chose qui devrait nous
interroger tu conclu la séquence en
disant que c'est normal car le mérite
n'existe pas alors là j'ai vraiment du
mal à comprendre parce que de deux
choses l'une monter soit on déplore que
les plus talentueux ne soient pas ceux
qui ont le plus de succès auquel cas on
admet la notion de mérite puisque on
voudrait qu'elle soit appliquée soit on
considère que le mérite n'existe pas
comme tu la firme mais dans ce cas là
bas y'a pas de problème en fait on peut
pas à la fois nié l'existence du mérite
et être chagriné du fait que le mérite
n'est pas récompensé comme il devrait
l'être
ce que je veux dire c'est que si tu
t'étonnes que le succès ne soit pas
corrélées au mérite c'est justement
parce que tu estimes que ce mérite
existe bel et bien parce que ces cours
ne disent pas tu le mérites
c'te pas ça c'est toi qui l'affirment ce
que disent ses courbes c'est que le
mérite n'est pas un facteur déterminant
dans la mécanique du succès puis
d'ailleurs depuis début de cette vidéo
on parle uniquement du mérite des
personnes qui accède à la célébrité ou à
la richesse mais si on ramène sans
manutentionnaires qui se lève à 3h du
matin ou à la caissière de chez auchan
payés au smic est-ce que tu diras que
ces personnes n'ont pas de mérite c'est
sans réalité qui m'a poussé à faire
cette vidéo parce qu'autant je comprends
l'idée qu'il ya des métiers où le succès
n'est pas dû au mérite comme les métiers
de la bourse ou à la spéculation en
général autant déclarer purement et
simplement que le mérite n'existe pas
c'est une affirmation qui a des
conséquences beaucoup plus lourdes se
connaît pas et je ne voudrais pas te
prêter des opinions qui ne sont pas les
tiennent mais tu vas plutôt l'air de
quelqu'un qui défend les classes
populaires donc quand tu dis que le
mérite n'existe pas tu dis aux prolos
qui fait les trois huit ou à la mère de
famille qui charbonneau pour payer son
loyer qui n'ont pas plus de mérite que
le trader de wall street où le rentier
mobilier c'est ça la conclusion logique
de ton raisonnement tu ne dis pas parce
que tu ne le pense pas mais
l'argumentation tu défends conduit à
cette conclusion que tu le veuilles ou
non
pourquoi devrait-on s'élever contre les
inégalités sociales si les dominés n'ont
pas plus de mérite que les dominants
pourquoi devrait on trouvait injuste que
ceux qui travaillent gagnent moins que
ceux qui font travailler les autres à
moins justement d'accorder une valeur à
la notion de mérite
en fait j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un
gros malentendu quand on parle du mérite
c'est qu'on confond le mérite et le
privilège tu en parles un peu plus loin
dans ta vidéo mais je vais aborder ce
point maintenant parce que c'est très
important
le mérite ce n'est pas le privilège lui
mérite c'est l'antidote contre le
privilège le privilège c'est ce dont on
hérite par notre naissance c'est à dire
de manière parfaitement indépendante de
nos efforts alors que le mérite c'est
justement la construction de notre
réussite par nos efforts personnels et
d'ailleurs tu reconnais toi même dans ta
vidéo que la méritocratie a rendu la
société plus égalitaire au moment de
l'abolition de la monarchie étant donné
qu'elle mettait fin aux privilèges de
l'aristocratie tu affirmes que le
privilège qu'il mérite ce avec quoi je
suis totalement d'accord
et dans le même temps tu fais comme si
c'était la notion de mérite qui posait
problème
il ya une incohérence on ne peut pas à
la fois dénoncer les privilèges et
critiqué le mérite comme on ne peut pas
à la fois défendre les travailleurs
aient nié le mérite des travailleurs et
si je te rejoins entièrement sur le fait
que la réussite est hélas bien souvent
une affaire de privilèges c'est
justement parce qu'elle n'est pas une
affaire de mérite et encore moins une
affaire de hasard
un enfant de couvreur zingueur ne part
pas avec le même bagage qui a un fils de
profs qui emmène ses gamins au musée
tous les premiers dimanches du mois
aucune avocate qui payent des cours
d'anglais à ces gamins dès la maternelle
comme le défend bien ce papier la
méritocratie est en effet aujourd'hui
largement devenue une parente au cra si
c'est à dire un système où la
reproduction sociale est très largement
conditionnés et décidé par vos parents
on est comme retourner à la case départ
la sociologie nous le rappelle sans
cesse en nous montrant à quel point
l'origine et la position sociale sont
des facteurs bien plus déterminant dans
le succès que bat tout le reste
finalement comment défendre l'égalité
des chances dans un environnement où
tout le monde ne part pas du même
endroit à ce moment ta vidéo montée
j'oserais dire que tu me donnent raison
puisque tu aborde enfin la question des
privilèges qui me semble hélas je te
rejoins la question déterminante puisque
comme toi je ne crois pas en l'égalité
des chances au sens où les inégalités
sociales sont un fait est qu'elles
déterminent en grande partie nos chances
de parvenir ou pas au succès de couy
clairement un fils de médecin a plus de
chances de devenir médecin que le fils
du boulanger ou la fille de la fleuriste
mais est ce que tu vois monter que ce
que tu dis à ce moment précis de la
vidéo entre totalement en contradiction
avec mon argumentation sur la chance tu
dis et je reprends tes mots que la
sociologie nous rappelle que ce sont ces
privilèges qui constituent les facteurs
déterminant du succès mais si le facteur
déterminant du succès c'est l'origine
sociale
ça ne peut donc pas être la chance si
l'origine sociale conditionne le succès
comment le succès pourrait-il être en
même temps le fruit du hasard
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui m'a
frappé dans ta vidéo ce revirement
argumentatif qui te fait passer de
l'argument du hasard à l'argument du
déterminisme social alors même que le
déterminisme social c'est le contraire
du hasard à moins d'aller dans un
raisonnement qui consiste à dire oui
mais l'origine sociale on n'a pas choisi
dont quelque part c'est du hasard mais
je pense pas que ce soit ça parce qu'à
ce moment-là ça revient à dire que tout
est hasard et que rien au hasard donc ça
n'a pas de sens pourquoi pas après tout
on peut partir dans des paradoxes
métaphysique ça me dérange pas du tout
c'est ma passion
mais d'un point de vue sociologique soit
on explique le succès par le
déterminisme social sont l'expliquent
par le hasard mais pas les deux à la
fois c'est juste une question de
cohérence logique en fait quelle que
soit l'option qu'on privilégie et là
forcément une des deux qui se retrouve
exclue est ce un peu ça le problème avec
les affirmations radical en philosophie
c'est à dire les explications mono
causale c'est qu'il ya forcément un
moment où rencontre unis
qui fait qu'on est obligé de se
contredire et pour te montrer en quoi
ces deux arguments sont contradictoires
l'un avec l'autre
on va prendre un exemple emblématique
qui est l'exemple des grandes écoles qui
va dans les grandes écoles ce sont les
enfants des familles aisées en règle
générale ce sont les privilégiés et
pourquoi ces enfants vont-ils dans les
grandes écoles précisément parce que
leurs parents savent qu'en passant par
une grande école
ils auront beaucoup plus de chances de
réussir et donc si le succès n'était
qu'une affaire de chance si vraiment
c'était le hasard qui décide et il n'y
aurait aucune raison d'envoyer ses
enfants dans des grandes écoles
on se contentera de miser sur la chance
qu'on me sur un numéro à la roulette du
casino le raisonnement d'un parent qui
on voit son enfant dans une grande école
il est très simple c'est de se dire si
mon enfant passe par une grande école il
aura plus de chances qu'un autre d'être
pris dans une grande entreprise
il aura donc plus de chances d'avoir des
prétentions salariales élevées
il aura donc plus de chances de réussir
sa vie le fait est que ce raisonnement
est parfaitement valide
c'est la logique même de la reproduction
sociale dont tu parles dans ta vidéo et
que bourdieu a théorisé à travers les
notions de capitale culturelle et de
domination symbolique passer par une
grande école c'est réduire autant que
faire se peut l'influencent du hasard
c'est mettre toutes les chances de son
côté et quand on met toutes les chances
de son côté
c'est qu'on a décidé de supprimer le
facteur chance
sur youtube c'est également vrai la
position au sein du microcosme social
c'est à dire ce que certains
appelleraient youtube game party
déterminant comme le fait d'avoir un
bagage intellectuel et technique fort si
comme moi vous faites de la
vulgarisation un portage ou nicolas
peuvent apporter bien plus de monde que
des années de travail acharné des
capacités techniques en vidéo peut vous
faire épargner je sais pas moi disons un
ou deux ans de galère si on compare la
situation avec celle de vos pairs et
encore on n'a pas parlé du matériel
parce que commencer avec une webcam le
g15 de panasonic que j'utilise
actuellement ça change la façon dont on
va ou jugés sur votre image parce que si
c'est pas impossible d'avoir un truc
trop avec une logithèque 920
c'est vrai que c'est pas impossible
c'est quand même plus simple avec un
truc qui filme en 4k en flat et qui peut
faire du slow motion un peu style et
prenez moi par exemple le fait que j'ai
sympathisé très tôt avec des gens de la
vinothèque d'alexandrie comme nota bene
ni copilote
mais les hôtes dirty biology bah ça a
certainement aidé machine à décoller pas
par des partages ou tout simplement par
des conseils techniques des opportunités
de boulot les invitations en événements
moi je sais pas j'ai travaillé avec nico
sur la chaîne de tam est né par exemple
parlera pas été possible si nous
n'étions pas de but à vie à la basse
typiquement ces relations ont apporté du
boulot de l'expérience est donc une
pérennisation de mon activité économique
sur youtube ça a joué 9 chez les amis
qu'on des grosses communautés qui
partagent mes vidéos ça contribue aussi
certainement à leur succès qui j'ai eu
l'aide du cnc ça m'a permis d'investir
dans du matos et payer des costumes des
techniciens et c'était là largement
conditionné le succès critique en
commentaire de cette dernière année et
le step up en termes de matériel en
termes de technique en terme de durée en
termes de tout ce que vous voulez que je
veux c'est qu'une société de prod aussi
où nous sommes plusieurs vidéaste puis
vint les opportunités des uns deviennent
souvent des opportunités les autres sans
que le facteur talent soit le plus
déterminant face à d'autres comme la
disponibilité
lui pris la ligne éditoriale c'est comme
ça que j'ai eu une offre vpn par exemple
t'as permis de me payer ma vidéo sur le
fiqh et payés gagnent pour réaliser
trois plans 3d sur la vidéo qui parle de
l'homme langues
des fois ça tient vraiment encore à
moins que ça j'ai pu créer une langue
pour la série cause par exemple car
quelqu'un a tagué mon nom sous un tweet
de timoteo c'est juste ça enfin bref sur
youtube comme ailleurs l'égalité des
chances ou le mérite sont des chimères
et des fantasmes et donc des notions
caduque
alors là mon cher montée j'ai trouvé
cette séquence de ta vidéo
particulièrement intéressante parce
qu'elle illustre parfaitement ce que
j'appellerais le biais du vainqueur
ingrat le biais du vainqueur ingrat ça
consiste à dire je suis parvenu au
succès en suivant tel chemin mais si
vous suivez exactement le même chemin
il est quasiment certain que vous ne
réussirez pas en fait c'est exactement
la même chose que le biais du survivant
mais dans le sens inverse
au lieu de dire le fait que j'ai réussi
et la preuve que vous aussi vous pouvez
réussir tu dis le fait que j'ai réussi
et totalement indépendant de ce que j'ai
entrepris pour réussir tu expliques ton
succès par le seul facteur chance vont
nous expliquer que quoi qu'on fasse
la réussite ne dépend pas de nous comme
un champion olympique du 100 m qui
dirait non mais les gars je suis
champion mais en fait la chance donc ça
ça va vous entraîner et encore si avec
ça on pourrait dire oh qu'elle soit il
relativise son succès parce qu'il n'a
pas le sentiment d'être meilleure qu'un
autre très bien c'est une preuve de
maturité mais en fait pas du tout tu
expliques toi même comment s'est
construite on succès et en l'expliquant
tu montres que ton succès ne rien le
fruit du hasard
parce que si je résulte que tu dans ta
vidéo c'est que si tu n'avais pas fait
tout ce que tu as fait tu n'aurais
jamais rencontré le succès c'est très
exactement ce que tu dit dans la vidéo
c'est l'enchaînement de tout ce que tu
as fait et de tout ce qui t'es arrivé
qui t'a conduit à la situation actuelle
mais ça mon ami ça s'appelle pas de la
chance ça s'appelle saisir les
opportunités et je sais ce que tu vas me
dire tu vas me dire que les opportunités
se sont créés et indépendamment de ta
volonté et que par conséquent tu n'as
aucun mérite à les avoir saisi mais moi
je te dis tu te trompes montée tu te
trompe pas ce que tu fais comme si ces
opportunités qui se sont présentées à
toi était totalement indépendante de tes
actions
moi ce que je te dis c'est que ce sont
des actions qui ont permis aux
opportunités de secret alors oui la
chance tu as aidé au sens wall a
amplifié les retombées de ton travail
est d'ailleurs tu parles de la chance
mais tu n'évoque jamais la malchance qui
fait que les deux phénomènes aléatoires
ce qu'on pense et ses compétences
techniques qui t'ont aidé il
à lui les acquiert ses amis avec
lesquels tu as fait des collabos il a
bien fallu qu'ils deviennent des amis
cet internaute quitte à taguer sur
twitter il a bien fallu que tu fasses
des vidéos pour qu'ils te connaissent
il a bien fallu que tu agissent pour
créer ces opportunités que tu as ensuite
exploitées à ton avantage mais ne se
serait rien passé si tu n'avais rien
fait en amont ce que je veux dire c'est
que ce en même temps rendre compte tu
viens de décrire précisément ce que j'ai
appelé tout à l'heure la mécanique du
succès à savoir toutes les actions
secondaires qui concourent à l'obtention
d'un résultat positif
en fait j'ai l'impression que tu pars du
principe que ce qui nous arrive est
totalement étranger à nos actions et que
si on n'a pas cherché à provoquer
exactement ce qu'on a provoqué on ne
peut pas s'en attribuer le mérite parce
qu on est bien d'accord que nos actions
ou une incidence sur la réalité est que
quand on fait quelque chose on crée
forcément des opportunités qui n'aurait
pas existé sans notre action si tu
publies une vidéo sur youtube
tu crées la possibilité que des gens la
voient et parmi les gens qui vont la
voir il y en a qui vont l'apprécier et
parmi ceux qui vont l'apprécier il y en
a qui vont la partager et parmi ceux qui
vont la partager il y en a qui seront
suivis par une grosse communauté c'est
un simple effet de levier probabiliste
plus ta vidéo sera vue plus elle aura de
chances d'être partagé par un internaute
ayant une grosse communauté qui
regardent jamais fait un graphique pour
te montrer
donc même si tu n'avais pas cet objectif
en tête au moment où tu as publié la
vidéo
il n'empêche qu'en publiant ta vidéo tu
as créé les conditions pour que cet
événement se produise ton action a
déployé ses effets et même si cela
n'était pas dans l'intention initiale
le problème de l'argumentation tu
défends montée c'est qu'elle fait passer
pour de la chance ce qui relève en fait
de l'initiative et que si on se met à
appeler chance toutes les initiatives
dont on ne contrôle pas l'intégralité
des conséquences parce que c'est ce que
tu dis tu dis que ce qui est
partiellement imputable au hasard ne
peut pas être inclus dans le mérite pas
ça revient est purement et simplement la
valeur de tout ce qu'on entreprend
j'ai décidé d'appeler cette séquence le
biais du vainqueur ingrat parce que sous
des apparences d'humilité l'humilité
dont je ne doute pas qu'elle soit
sincère et réel dans sa démarche le
message que tu véhicules dans ta vidéo
est un message non seulement contraire à
la réalité mais aussi profondément
démobilisateur passe qui consiste à dire
que quoi qu'on fasse et quelles que
soient nos efforts le résultat ne dépend
pas de nous et ça comme je lé démontré
tout au long de cette vidéo c'est tout
simplement faux quand j'ai lancé ma
chaîne youtube il ya maintenant un peu
plus de deux ans mon but n'était pas de
devenir célèbre certaines de mes vidéos
ont rencontré un réel succès comme celle
sur le stoïcisme ou celle sur spinoza
qui ont enregistré plusieurs centaines
de milliers de vues en appel quelques
elle alors que j'y parle pas non plus de
40 minutes de concepts abstraits sans
aucun montage et sans avoir préparé mon
texte quand j'ai vu que mes vidéos de
philosophie plaisait autant je ne me
suis pas dit que c'était de la chance je
me suis dit que je venais de mettre le
doigt sur un paramètre qui m'avait jusqu
alors échappé à paramètre qui devenait
une fois que j'en avais pris conscience
un paramètre maîtrisable à savoir que
les gens s'intéressent aux vidéos de
philosophie et aujourd'hui quand je
publie une vidéo scripté avec un montage
dynamique et qu'elle dépasse à peine et
10000 vue je ne me dis pas tu le mérites
n'existe pas je me dis seulement qu'il
ya des paramètres du succès qu'on ne
soupçonne pas forcément au départ et
qu'on apprend à connaître à force de
persévérance et d'expérimentation ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut se lancer des
fleurs et dire qu'on est le meilleur
ça veut simplement dire qu'il est
possible d'augmenter nos chances de
réussir en agissant sur les paramètres
maîtrisable et qu'il est trop facile de
faire porter le chapeau au hasard si un
jeune qui veut se lancer sur youtube
vient de voir en convention et te
demandent quel est ton meilleur conseil
qu'est ce que tu vas lui répondre de
faire confiance au hasard
permets moi d'en douter
[Musique]
mais la vérité c'est que nous n'avons
parfois aucun contrôle sur les
évènements
la plupart du temps et peut-être même
donc nous sommes pas responsables ni
maître de notre destin nous pourrions
sinon prédire le succès et rien n'est
moins aisés et là les amis je vous
emmène du côté du déterminisme
alors j'ai pas vous refaire tout le
débat terminologie que j'ai pu avoir
avec monsieur fille qui serait bien plus
précis et certainement bien plus
pertinent sur la question et le
déterminisme est une notion selon
laquelle tout est déterminé selon le
principe de causalité par ce qui fut
précédemment pinosa qui a théorisé le
nécessite à risque une notion très
proche explique alors qu aucune liberté
ne peut exister si nos choix sont
orientés par des éléments épars des
critères extérieurs le libre arbitre
n'existe pas seule l'illusion du libre
arbitre existe
spinoza ce grand philosophe du xviie
siècle auquel on se réfère allègrement
dès qu'on veut démontrer que le libre
arbitre n'existe pas spinoza grands
penseurs mme espinosa coni généralement
pas jusqu'au bout car je note qu'à
chaque fois qu'on mentionne spinoza sur
la question de la liberté c'est toujours
pour citer ce qu'il dit dans le livre un
de l'éthique son oeuvre principale est
jamais ce qu'il dit dans le livre 5 à
savoir que la liberté humaine existe et
qu'on peut l'atteindre dans le livre
revient de l'éthique spinoza explique en
quoi tout est soumis au déterminisme
implacable de la causalité
si nous ne sommes pas libres c'est parce
que toutes nos actions mais aussi toutes
nos pensées sont le résultat d'un
enchaînement de causes et d'effets dont
nous ne sommes que les réceptacle passif
spinoza montre que ce que nous appelons
la liberté n'est en fait que l'ignorance
des causes qui nous déterminent je crois
être libre d'agir de telle ou telle
manière quand je n'ai pas conscience de
ce qui me pousse
c'est sur la base de ce même
raisonnement que spinoza réfute
l'existence du hasard car dans une
vision déterministe le hasard n'existe
pas il n'y a que des causes et des
effets pour spinoza la liberté est une
illusion au sens où dans le règne des
causes et des effets tout a une raison
d'être
sauf que la liberté que conteste spinoza
et ça ça suppose de connaître un peu
l'histoire des idées c'est la liberté
telle que définie par descartes et par
le christianisme à savoir la liberté
comme capacité à s'extraire de la chaîne
de causalité ce que spinoza appel
l'indétermination spinoza ni
l'indétermination c'est à dire l'idée
d'une liberté absolue
mme espinosa ne nie absolument pas
l'existence d'une liberté relative ce
qu'il appelle l'auto déterminer
il n'ya pas liberté absolue tout
simplement parce qu'il est impossible de
sortir de la chaîne des causes et des
effets mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'homme ne soit pas capable d'accéder à
une liberté relative et pour te le
prouver je vais prendre un exemple très
concret entre un homme accro à l'héroïne
est un homme qui n'a aucune addiction à
la drogue
lequel est le plus libre est-ce que tu
oserait prétendre qu être accro à
l'héroïne ne rend pas moins libre que de
ne pas l'être bien sûr que non c'est
bien la preuve que la liberté est
quelque chose de graduelle ce n'est
jamais un absolu on est plus ou moins
libre celui qui n'a aucune addiction à
la drogue reste dépendant de l'oxygène
qu'il respire de la nourriture qu'ils
mangent est ce que pour autant on irait
dire que les deux situations sont
équivalentes
la liberté ce n'est pas un interrupteur
on off la liberté c'est un intervalle
sur lequel se déplace un curseur entre
deux extrémités est la question que pose
spinoza c'est de savoir comment monter
le curseur le plus haut possible
même si on sait qu'il est impossible de
s'affranchir de certaines contraintes
inhérentes à notre condition d'être
physique parce que si le libre arbitre
n'existe pas alors l'endoctrinement
n'existe pas non plus puisque
l'endoctrinement suppose un libre
arbitre qu'il va dissoudre
ça veut dire que l'addiction n'existe
pas non plus puisque la diction suppose
un libre arbitre qu'elle va anéantir
si le libre arbitre n'existe pas tout ce
qui altère le libre arbitre n'existe pas
non plus et c'est ça le problème quand
on nie purement et simplement
l'existence du libre arbitre
c'est que ça revient à nier tout ce qui
diminue notre libre arbitre de
l'addiction à l'hallucination en passant
par la contrainte physique ou la
manipulation psychologique
la liberté ça n'est pas et ça ne sera
jamais un absolu et pour le comprendre
il suffisait d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
lecture de l'éthique jusqu'aux livres 5
dans lequel spinoza nous explique
comment la raison peut nous aider à
desserrer l'emprise de nos passions sur
le corps et d'agir en individu libre
j'ai achevé ce que je m'étais proposer
expliqué concernant la puissance de
l'âme sur ses passions et la liberté de
l'homme les principes que j'ai établi
font voir clairement la supériorité du
sage sur l'ignorant que l'aveuglent
passion conduit celui-ci autres qu'il
est agité en mille sens divers par les
causes extérieures et ne possède jamais
la véritable paix de l'âme vie dans
l'oubli de lui-même de dieu et de toute
chose et pour lui si c'est de pâtir cc
c'est d'être au contraire
l'amdi
je peux à peine être troublé la voix que
j'ai montré pour atteindre jusque là par
et rapide mieux sans doute est certes il
faut qu'un but si rarement atteints soit
bien difficile à poursuivre car si le
salut était sous la main comment se
fait-il qui fut négligé par presque tous
tout ce qui est beau et difficile
auteur carrère spinoza mythique fans
fait livrer 5 et c'est ça que je
reproche à ceux qui prétendent que le
libre arbitre n'existe pas c'est de
partir d'une définition de la liberté
qui n'a aucun sens d'un point de vue
humain c'est qu'ils prélèvent quelques
citations chez un philosophe qui n'ont
généralement pas lui sans en avoir saisi
la portée profonde et véritable en
conclusion charmante et je salue ton
travail de pédagogie que je trouve
absolument positif et les personnes
comme toi sont très précieuses sur
youtube
je t'invite à faire preuve de davantage
de nuances quand tu aborde des sujets
philosophiques
car contrairement à d'autres disciplines
c'est un domaine dans lequel la
compréhension est tributaire de
l'interprétation est une interprétation
un peu trop simpliste peut nous conduire
à des erreurs de jugement le problème de
la liberté est un problème complexe en
philosophie et même si la sociologie
démontre que nous sommes en grande
partie gouverné par des déterminismes
sociaux le vtec il ne suffit pas de
proclamer que nous ne sommes pas libres
pour nous débarrasser de ce fardeau
proprement humain qu'est la liberté
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce
n'oubliez pas de la partager de la
commenter
rejoignez-moi sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook instagram twitter tous les
liens sont dans la description merci
infiniment à tous les souscripteurs et à
tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur tipi on
se retrouve prochainement pour un nouvel
épisode
et d'ici là plus que jamais
soyez sages
[Musique]